[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
it's almost like the last show ended the
show just began
uh amen welcome to
fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernard
we're back at the cantina it's friday
night
no one's paid no one's working
shit's gone weird um it's uh another
uh summer 2020 night ladies and
gentlemen
which means we're the only game in town
what else you gonna do yeah really
you're home and [ __ ] you're like it's
this or tiger king again
have you ever been on instagram and it
gives you the message
you've seen all of the posts no
i i hit that once it was like you hit
the wall i hit the wall i hit the you've
seen it all
wall and i'm trying it just says go out
we're done here go live a life he's like
dial
are you okay um and i feel like lots of
people are getting there on like the
netflix's
and the peacocks we can even talk about
they just dropped peacock
and uh recently and i just i literally
just downloaded it on my apple tv what
did i watch tonight
the first thing i rolled on peacock was
dateline
wow my wife is a huge true crime person
so you know i try to meet her sometimes
in her world
i don't like [ __ ] like that because i'd
rather you know
like fantasy yeah you know what i'm
saying like if
if if there's a true crime i want batman
to punch it in the [ __ ]
mouth and that's how it's solved and
[ __ ] and it goes to arkham but
like she watches these true crime things
we just watched one where
like this this chick was
lo slowly poisoned with nicotine did you
even know this was a thing
no cause i mean i knew smoking would
kill you but i didn't know that that was
an actionable thing this guy would put
it in her food
and then he'd put it in her [ __ ]
bathtub he hid it in her
salad dressing and then he put in her
bathtub so like she's constantly
[ __ ] soaking in nicotine and it
causes you know [ __ ]
vomiting and poison she's he slowly
slowly poisoned her
with [ __ ] nicotine and i'm like
what the [ __ ] would batman do about that
it's
it's the very intimate version of
poisoning the reservoir right
yeah no smiling fish no smiling fish i'm
gonna pour this gunk into the [ __ ]
sad story of a marriage gone south
and i i tell you i don't know why like
she knows them all i think she's
plotting my death
but as i sit there and watch every one
of these i'm like why does anybody ever
try to commit a murder
like you rarely get away with it like
based on dateline they never get away
with it i would watch a true crime show
if it was like
true daffy crimes like i don't want
murder to be the [ __ ] crime
yeah like if it was a little like
there's i was listening to this story
um it was an article first but it got
turned into a podcast episode
about this dude and i want to say
finland it's probably not
whatever but who staged a heist of a
million dollars worth of exotic
rare fishing lures because there's an
entire [ __ ] like collector's market
for these things and there's some birds
that are extinct
i mean i know this is wrong but that's
almost like a victimless crime
it 100 i mean i know somebody lost a
million dollars worth of lures but like
but it was from a museum and they're
insured and it's just but it
like the story's like you know what
never knew this was a culture
never knew that nobody got hurt did
somebody get convicted
um somebody got caught and there was a
sort of process in which he essentially
just like played and
walked off on on on some kind of
probation
but like you don't go to hard you don't
do hard times for stealing they're still
those
you know i mean it's the it's the the
maple syrup heist
thing i bet you those cats do hard times
that happen in canada and they take
maple syrup
[ __ ] seriously they do but they're
like that's the only thing we put people
to debt for
up here eh commit a murder is fine
steal the maple syrup you're going
straight to hell [ __ ]
but like that kind of [ __ ] like if
you're gonna tell me about the sweetest
crime about dudes who stole a tanker
full of maple syrup
i will happily listen to lester holt
walk me through that story
dateline uh what would it be called
dateline date light date light you know
what i'm saying like stories where
they treat it they give it the same
treatment same structure
same score but no dire consequences
if it was just like true crime question
mark and you have to like wonder if this
[ __ ] is real like
did somebody really steal these [ __ ]
exotic fishing lures that'd be good man
if they
if date light or or if true crime
question mark was every other episode
like you're watching it and it's [ __ ]
like holy [ __ ] man this is
[ __ ] like did this happen and then
they introduced a character from fiction
so we're like oh [ __ ] the batman [ __ ]
yeah
scooby doo the guys dogs with scooby doo
just when you're thinking like this
shit's real they're like and then
children in a van with a dog
intervened and saved the day and you're
like you sons of [ __ ] you got me and
they're like welcome to date laughs
yeah with lester holt lester ha i'm told
everything was going swimmingly until
jessica fletcher showed up
she now i that's that's all i looked at
on peacock but
i i it seemed impressive they had movies
too
like it's i guess that's the nbc
universal yeah app so all the universal
[ __ ] goes there as well um
some of it and then some of it's kind of
random like i was scrolling through and
they're like
the matrix trilogy it's like that's
warner bros yeah that's right
i i too was the little flum expert
that's on your home page like why are
you touting that
yeah meanwhile over on hbo max they're
like
anyone see the matrix do they have the
matrix as well
they do but it seems as if like it's a
zoo where some shit's going from one
pen to the other pen like why are the
rhinos in with the zebras well because
the licensing agreements weren't up yet
wow how messy but peacock looks all
right
it looks all right i haven't watched
there was a few shows
that were like made for peacock that are
like ready to go already yeah
brave new world is their big shiny thing
what is it
um based on the the aldous huxley
science fiction novel
written by grant morrison wrote the
pilot the [ __ ] for brave new world
relevant to our interests starring han
solo himself alden ehrenreich oh get out
of here yeah
nice to see him working still good actor
yeah he took a little bit of a
of a public quiet time after solo
i mean it wasn't his fault no but it's
just like he's like you know what
i i don't need to be out in the public
eye i'm going to just do my [ __ ] make
this show
where can i go to not be seen i know
peacock
um would it just did it just launch
like two days ago the 15th so it hadn't
there was no soft launch prior to this
nope these guys are just coming out of
the gate uh they got it all they got
i'll tell you what i'm going to be
[ __ ] using peacock for tonight using
them and abusing it
go to sleep to frasier oh they got the
frasier's up there man
so you could just roll them yeah go to
sleep so [ __ ] like a warm blanket
i'm gonna watch me a whole lot of
rockford files they have that yeah
been
[Applause]
remember back then when they had like 10
hours just to do the theme
song and like hey before the show begins
guys
we got a moog so this is going to be
synthesizer [ __ ] heavy
just wait
oh man i don't mean to blow out the ears
of anybody at home
because i'm sure i just did didn't mean
it but you may have blown out the ears
but you turned some people on man you
hit the high moog sound
like a [ __ ] tomcat in the back alley
not this back alex this is where the you
find [ __ ] on your way in let's not catch
you
no home human person [ __ ] um it's been a
hell of a week uh it's been five days
since you looked at me
holy [ __ ] bear naked bernard in here um
the uh we were when did we was it last
friday
last friday so in one week there was the
other day i was like mark's like we're
doing a show i was like i don't know
anything happened
and then in 48 hours news happened and
suddenly it was worth having a [ __ ]
show
we got [ __ ] to talk about do you have
anything that you did this week that's
life is starting to [ __ ] numbingly
resemble
i know the same way everyone's been like
it's the same [ __ ] day and i've i've
been agreeing up till now but for me it
really hasn't but now it is starting to
take on this kind of
yeah what day is it yeah insane day
my my week at least is structured by
celebrity show-off the uh the tbs show
because there's a day
we have to shoot the short and there's a
day that we have to shoot the stage
show so that like basically my sunday
and my
thursday are structured everything else
is kind of free-form
um but i've been working on some stuff i
did recording today
remotely for masters of the universe um
all the recording sessions now you know
one person here one person here one
person there and stuff
the other day we finished up lena heady
stuff which was
awesome she was she's over in the uk and
so it was like early in the morning for
us like eight am but whatever time it is
over there
she was i could just listen to her
[ __ ] all day long man
she just like brings it and choose that
[ __ ] dialogue makes it like it oh
it's so
good no
think anybody in your life put the word
have him say the word wretched she beats
them
the way she's like wretched oh so [ __ ]
how does wretched have six syllables
i know she does she [ __ ] drags it out
uh
steven root finished up all his cringer
stuff
absolutely wonderful um who else we
we finished up chris wood all the he-man
adam step we finished
finished up sarah michelle gellar
for all the tila stuff and today was
like all mark and so
all the skeletor stuff is now wow
recorded um i've heard now
all of the scripts brought to life i've
heard the last line
of the shows so it's it's been
fantastic man that that aspect has been
wonderful and then doing it from home
is nuts because like today while mark
was doing it i was just eating while he
was
it was like eating and watching a movie
and [ __ ] it's better than netflix
take that one again yeah one more i'm
sorry i couldn't hear
cause i was chewing this potato chip
dipped in peanut butter my bad um so
there's a bit of that
the mode 2 proceeds very well
the powerhouse animation stuff i've now
seen
six animatics and [ __ ] they are
astounding
so so far so good there what have you
been up to
uh this week has been um a lot of zoom
action and a lot of moderating of things
action
um not for comic-con per se but dc
reached out for a couple panels for
their
dc fandom are you working the fandom
we're going to fandom i can't say the
panels that i'm moderating we'll find
you beneath the fandom
i will be basking under the fandom wow
man yeah hopefully not uh
confronted by murder under the
underdefender
but so like prepping for those things
and scheduling and research and watching
when is fandom do you know i believe
it's it's
mid-august um but much like i think
comic-con has been pre-taping a lot of
their panels but dc is doing the same
thing
um so yeah man it's it's been fun but
kind of getting back into that
moderating saddle of like all right i
got to conduct this conversation
and you're doing it remotely too by zoom
so
at least the pressure of walking into a
room full of you know 6 000 people
isn't there right but they're still the
best part though it is pretty cool
you know like yeah i just
it is a poor substitute for comic-con
still you were invited
i was not invited under the fandom no
but you got to you got to spend some
time with bill and ted
i did i did i was a welcome over at
comic-con and stuff
i'll be a fan dome a spectator and
whatnot cheering you on from the
sidelines
going how's the food mark oh it's really
good here in this green room
pass out one of them bat brownies
[Laughter]
but yeah so a bit of that um a lot of
video gaming this has been a big video
game week for
me really what are you playing playing
this game called the last of us part
two okay the one that they're making the
hbo show correct they're making
i think that the hbo show is very much
about the first game which is great and
fantastic
but this is you know it it's an
astounding piece
of storytelling it's it's more than just
a hey the
the gameplay mechanics are cool and the
combat's fun and
this is a very like well wrought
and incredibly well-fashioned kind of
treaties on trauma
and and blame and forgiveness and
i don't know if you know very much about
these games at all
but it the the first game last of us
presents like it's just
another zombie game right where oh
there's been an outbreak and
oh things are going bad and then we're
in the post-apocalypse where like you
know
cities are overgrown and cars don't work
and nobody's got gas and you're
scavenging for
whatever but it's a story about this
dude who
gets hired to escort this young girl 14
15 years old
from you know massachusetts to like
chicago
across this sort of hellish wasteland
and what he doesn't know about this job
at the beginning is that this is the one
person in the entire world so far who's
immune
to this disease and so he's got to take
her to these doctors who
want to synthesize a cure and a vaccine
for everybody
a little too timely yeah really um
and so but he wants anything to do with
it he wants something to do with her and
then we begin to realize that their
relationship
their own history of what they've gone
through he had a daughter who died early
on
and so he begins to sort of cleave to
this girl and begins to see her as
something of a surrogate
you know she had shitty relationships
with her dad and her parents and she's
been an orphan for a while and she got
to watch her parents die
all of those things that happened and
then it gets to the end of this game
and i'll spoil it only because the
game's like six years old
um but you get to the end of the game
and what the the big moral decision is
he takes her to the doctors who are
going to find the cure but in order to
get the cure from her
they have to kill her in the process
like the the
whatever's different in her brain it's
it's just they can't
get it out without unfortunately dooming
her
to a very early death and so he makes
this decision to
i'm going to take her out of here by
force i'll kill everybody that if i have
to but she's now my daughter and i
wouldn't allow you to kill my daughter
to i will save this one girl instead of
a million people
because that's a decision a father makes
like there's no there's no logic there's
no rationale that could convince you
that that that life is this you know
it's
it's worth it yeah that's worth it
that's pretty beautiful it's pretty
beautiful except it's really [ __ ]
dark because it makes
you as the player complicit in what is
ultimately
a war crime in a weird sort of way and
it makes you kill the doctors who are
just [ __ ] doctors to get this girl to
safety it makes you kill
everybody in this hospital to get her
out of there because otherwise they'll
kill you
otherwise i'll kill you they'll kill her
everything's gone remember when all you
had to do was just
reach the top and donkey kong fell on
his head and
the game was over [ __ ] what happened to
those are to get the frog over to the
other side five times and [ __ ]
you won the game now there's moral
ambiguity moral ambiguity and so the
game
ends you know where you get her back to
safety and she asks you the questions
like what happened in there
and he lies to her he tells her like
yeah they just couldn't figure out a way
to get the cure out
he doesn't tell her that by saving her
he's
doomed the world he's doomed the world
to continue this sort of like endless
horror
and and so the second game picks up kind
of where that leaves off where there's
this massive secret
seek secret secret between these two
characters right but
i mean it's gorgeous and it's lush and
new characters come in and
lots of similar kind of moral ambiguity
and hard choices and
and it's it's it's it's the best movie
i've seen in years except it's a video
game and it takes you 20
hours to get through but it's an amazing
20 hours
so when they do a the hbo series it'll
be the first one
it'll probably be the first one but it
wouldn't surprise me at all if
like it was a suite of these two games
stitched together into what could be
four seasons of tv
yeah it's dense and deep and lots of
lots of separate characters and side
missions and
yeah it's it's phenomenal um
sounds like uh modern-day legend of
zelda there mark
it's a little bit my reference time
really stopped 25 30 years ago
those games are too scary to me that's
where i feel like an old man when i see
a game like that where i'm like
hey man what am i doing am i jumping
over something they're like no you're
faced with a really tough decision
and also it's a horror game so you're
kind of going to get scared five or six
times an hour
jumps out yeah there's a lot of like
that thing tried to
beat my head off again pop culture has
passed me by man i don't understand
games like that
um and i i it's not like i don't respect
them but i'm like
i don't know i'm just you know they
released that jane sound bob mall brawl
game
that's my speed that's your speed side
scroller
something like that a couple levels
you're out
not this lifelong haunting commitment
that you carry with you like [ __ ]
herpes for the rest of your life like
it's one of two games you know the first
last of us
and red dead redemption 2 are both like
heartbreaking games to play really
because the endings are just
like sledgehammer in your soul but i
played them more than once just to get
that feeling again just to be like oh
just break my heart one more time just
do it
just just let me earn it just let me
earn this you've gotta you've gotta
you gotta issue i gotta talk to the
how long does it take to play red
what is it red dead redemption 2 i want
to say was like
30 hours 25 30 hours and so once you've
solved it or done it you would still be
willing
to do it again does it change at all
along the way um
there's the there's the level where you
play the game just to go from beginning
to end as quickly as you can
right and then there's a way to play the
game where you're just doing everything
possible the world is huge you can go
almost
anywhere you can i'm gonna go hunting
this month and just [ __ ] kill a bunch
of gear and then
cook it over fire and whatever like
there's that's the game
that's part of the game if you go off
the main narrative path
[ __ ] you can just like do all kinds of
[ __ ] i want to play poker like there's
an online poker
version of that game that's in the game
so it's like how you and me were on gary
wooda's animal talking show in the
middle of
a game totally where there's just people
who like maybe i'll stop by this island
what's happening oh there's a talk show
i'll watch the talk show for an hour
do you remember what was all so simple
as going in the one door on pac-man and
coming out the other side of the screen
mark
linear yeah simple i'm gonna do this
little ship here and there's a bunch of
asteroids and i'm going to shoot the
asteroids until they're in no more
other games scare me um so you spent
time do you play solo
yeah this game specifically there's no
multiplayer in this game it's just you
and the game
you know would people want like you know
other people watch on twitch people
playing games
would someone watch someone play a game
like this
i don't think so because there's enough
sort of cut scene narrative stuff in the
middle there
where everybody who plays it can watch
it it's not like watching you you can't
do that better than anybody else
right and there's there's kind of deep
just we're just dropping into story here
and it's basically watching a movie
um but yeah i suppose that there are
like
i mean there are walk through videos
because in case you get stuck and you're
like i don't know how to beat this level
or i don't know where to go
so you can watch people play it to get
better at it but i think the speed
through
like i'm gonna how fast can this dude
kill contra like
is not a thing i think people are doing
for this but i might be wrong because
the internet
everything that could happen everything
could be cocked man yeah
like was a rule 67 or something like if
you can think of it on the internet
somebody's done it
no doubt no doubt um but yeah it's it's
been a good
it's a fantastic game but it's also been
a good game
to sort of lose myself into a little bit
as the world continues to spiral
into things have not gotten better in
the seven days since we've done the show
no they in fact have gotten markedly
worse a lot
so much so that like you know it's
crazy that we're still like should we go
out and do a show
yeah the world particularly california
is on fire right now
but yeah like you know there's there's
been the general global
pandemic and the california pandemic and
the u.s insanity
but then there's also been like personal
tragedies that you know we'll kind of
get into at the tail end of the show
that have just kind of knocked i think
at the very least the nerd community
for a bit of a loop right um but before
that
well he should hit the news we can hit
some [ __ ] news that's why you tune
into this [ __ ] show cause you're like
in this age of up to the minute internet
news i don't know what's going on this
week
so you know who does these two guys you
know how they figured it out because
they put their nose to the grindstone
they looked up the [ __ ] that happened
between last week and this week man
newsman
mark bernard he pulled some news for you
give it up for mark he's got the news go
mark
i got some news
yeah you want it before we dive in the
news okay we got a birthday greeting
yeah one of our smart squad
evie it's evie's birthday you got evie's
photo we could throw up there look at
that that is mostly cat that is evie and
evie's human
i don't know that lady's name evie's the
cat no evie's the lady and that's evie's
cat
uh happy birthday evie uh from me and
mark
and the rest of the spots go off of jc
from andrew
from deacon from the ghosts
of scum and villainy from harley quinn
from everybody here everybody um so
uh all right into the news into the news
shall we little follow up from last week
um did you ever watch the old guard
after we had uh
i didn't um you were not alone
because it turns out that the old
guardians and when i watched it what the
[ __ ] do you no
well i can't speak for your house
um the old guard has easily become one
of the streamers top 10 most popular
movies
of all time of all time came from a
comic book it came from a comic book it
was viewed by 72 million
households in the first week wow
um wow to put that into some perspective
if each of those households
had just one person in it and that
person went to the movies to buy a
ticket to see old guard
and say that ticket was ten dollars well
i did it at 12.50 okay that's how this
math is going to work
um then it would have made 864 million
dollars
at the box office in the first week in
the opening week
in the opening week which is [ __ ]
critical why would anyone make a movie
for the movie theaters anymore man when
you could just
hit all those people at once without
spending all they they spent all the
money on the production
very little to nothing on advertising
yeah you know
and maybe some of it's the perfect storm
in which people aren't distracted let's
be honest
you got charlize theron she's running
around with an axe and [ __ ]
even even if you know if this was a
normal year
and people were out at the beach right
now that would still be getting
killer views yeah i mean netflix
netflix's top ten
uh they have a list they have a list of
their
highest watched movies start from 10 and
go up i'll start from 10 and go up yeah
from the bottom to the top
is the platform which i've never heard i
watched that yeah the sci-fi movie man
with the jail
right that's the 10th most watched 56
million households
i have seen the movie the netflix
original what's the
originals yeah yep
netflix's top 10 picks that they have
produced
and or distributed for netflix originals
so the platform is number 10.
wow the wrong missy
uh the david spade movie i'll take your
word for it is number nine
number nine triple frontier
ben affleck ben affleck number eight
number eight 63 million
the irishman you've heard of that
picture
[Music]
a bunch of newcomers right yeah
youngsters yeah directed by first timer
yeah yeah yeah um
at 64 million the old guard at 72
million
so wait the old guard is what number in
the list i believe that is number one
two
three four five six
so we have four left or five left
five left okay good yes murder mystery
um wait oh that's an adam sandler that's
in france
83 million how much 83 million
households
tied for that six underground starring
ryan reynolds directed by michael bay oh
yeah another 83 million households
spencer confidential mark wahlberg mark
wahlberg 85 million households
bird box sandy bullock which is
equalizing right
mm-hmm 89 million households and
extraction
with thor himself is the number one
99 million households wow man have
viewed that movie
and that was directed not by like you
know martin scorsese
or michael bay but by sam hargrave the
stunt
coordinator on the avengers movie that's
right
like he's part of the agbo outfit and so
you don't let anybody ever tell you like
you got to go to film school you got to
do this you got to do that
this man came up not this man mark but
this man we're talking about
came up through stunts presumably right
stunts fight coordination eventually
aggregated up to the fight coordinator
and then second unit now is directed
the biggest [ __ ] netflix movie most
watched netflix movie of all time
it's mind-bending kids the future is
wide open indeed um there is no right or
wrong
way well there's a wrong way there's
lots of wrong ways yeah but there's also
don't be a good way get in there pretty
much and then netflix announced today
that they are in business with the russo
brothers again
saw that this time for a film called the
gray man they're giving them
every dollar ever made 200 million
dollars plus
the highest budget ever for a netflix
movie wow um
and it's going to star chris evans and
ryan gosling and it's an espionage
thriller
but yeah they're not [ __ ] around
no they got all the money and why not
give it to those people
think about it we love the russo
brothers we love
chris evans especially today
is that one of the stories or no that
isn't but we can talk about it adorable
man
kid some little kid named bridger
his uh little sister was about to be
bitten by a
german shepherd and a kid put himself
between his little kid sister and the
german shepherd and the german shepherd
went adam apparently in his face
or something like that 92 stitches or
something ridiculous and uh
you know chris evans sent him a [ __ ]
video
and there's the kid dressed like captain
america with captain america mask on
and captain america himself is just like
pal
you're a hero that's what you are like
oh my god
it's like i'm gonna look up your address
pal i'm going to send you an authentic
captain america shield
because that's what you are you're a
hero hats off to you pretty amazing
bugging salutes the kid and the kids
like
i don't know if he can kid's like that
looks like the dude from knives out
[Laughter]
um it was adorable so he's in the movie
we all like him yeah right
goslings in the movie we all like him
that's that's a win-win across the
boards and they're saying that they want
it to be
like a spy franchise for them like
they're james bond yeah there's a couple
of
novels apparently that's a source
material um the russos wrote it with a
polish from
marcus and mcfeely because those guys
know what they're about
i'm sad to see marcus and mcfeely and
the russo brothers
you know not doing it in the marvel
universe but i'm happy for him i'll
watch the [ __ ] out of this but i just
wish everyone was
you know wearing a [ __ ] symbol on
their chest and keeping a mask that's
all i'm saying
those guys are good with those those
toys hear me out
shoot the movie once your way and then
do like one of them black and white cuts
but instead it's
the marvel cut just costumes who the
[ __ ] is
like gosling gonna play makes no sense
but i'm you know
sure kevin feige produced it so i'm good
uh this will be their first uh feige
list joint
all together um as directors yeah
and with with marx mcfeely yeah that
whole team right there
yeah yeah but exciting and they've
always like their their studio
agbo has always claimed to be sort of
platform agnostic like they would go
anywhere they don't have a deal set up
anywhere they have
independent financing it's like yeah we
can play with netflix we can go and do
this thing over here at fox we can go do
assassination
nation was that the movie that they
produced with uh
uh deadly deadly class that was a tv
show they did show did they produce
assassination
i think they did yeah it's a wonderful
flick i didn't see it i really enjoyed
it
well done it's about the guy that does
euphoria um what's his name's kid
which no nobody's kid ever wants to hear
that but he's the director i think he's
barry levinson's kid
sam levinson i believe you're right um
yeah i liked assassination nation they
they had something to do with that yeah
they produced that good for them that's
a classy flick
yeah so they're getting out there and
200 million uh
hot tick ready yeah get ready for this
internet get ready
to write your [ __ ] articles and [ __ ]
like that i'm gonna watch this
kevin smith going to watch the gray man
he's dropping that mic i like all the
people involved i'm all for it but yeah
and so when is it on next week
pretty much better be thursday run out
of [ __ ] to watch
first day we had talked a while back
about the likelihood of
movies like black widow or mulan or
the eternals or whatever going straight
to disney plus yes
the unlikelihood the unlikelihood of
that happening and and
at least my theory had always been
there's a price point at which
it no longer makes sense to go straight
to streaming where like you literally
need asses and seats to be able to
recoup that
that that level of expenditure true this
but if
netflix is going to spend 200 million
dollars on a movie
that's above that threshold in my head
my head was always like
120. you spend more than 120 million
dollars you have to go theatrical
in order to clear all of the ways you
need to clear but
apparently not no look at their top ten
yeah
like it proves them right every step of
the way just
[ __ ] spend you put the right people
in it because
you know they've got the algorithm they
know what everybody loves they know that
like movies with [ __ ] ryan gosling
get watched movies with
chris evans get watched they know that
the russo brothers and cats they want to
be in business with
and all makes sense like throw a bunch
of money on it because all they needed
to do is translate to a bunch of people
not just subscribing but staying
subscribed
you know that's like management that's
managing your your [ __ ]
audience by going like look man we're
not cheaping out look at this [ __ ]
yeah there must be math that makes sense
to them
that says you know what sure we we're
not converting each view into dollars
but the subscriptions then the
subscriber rate continues to go up our
retention
rate is insanely high we're not losing
customers
and so all right sure it's the same hbo
worked the same way like
you didn't pay more for game of thrones
than you paid
for everything else you're already
paying for hbo right but it worked for
them like you brought in a
[ __ ] ton of new people you brought in a
[ __ ] ton of new people you were like
boobies and dragons like that's not the
name of the show
is is that what you said to lena heady
like i really enjoyed your boobies and
dragons my god that boobies and dragons
show
she's like do you mean game of thrones
she said you're wretched
what wretched take is that uh also a
cockatoo
what else what else do we got um
how's the strawberry i mean i for this
to become a commercial
but i was so curious how's mark [ __ ]
around with the
with the non-beer beer what is it i do
there's bud lights
like salsa [ __ ] and so jc's got some
left in the bar every week i go like i
wonder if i want one and i don't do it i
just drink straight water but
the strawberry not so good is that right
it's too sweet
i mean well this this one from quasi
commercial to anti-commercial
don't do this don't drink this tastes
like [ __ ] swill yeah
what what is it competing is the
strawberry compete does it taste like
beer or alcohol at all not at all
basically it tastes like so it's hidden
it's hidden like they can hide the
caffeine in the bathtub
i learned that it's murder self that's
right
you're gonna find yourself bathing in
that and [ __ ]
people will be like how do you die
murder seltzer murders
strawberry scented my name is lester
halt true crime
it tastes like um i'm trying to
it's it's like [ __ ] sprite a little
bit with a flavor
it's like the [ __ ] pepper it's
strawberry perrier is it really
yeah but it has 100 calories because
yeah there's sugar in it because of it
because the booze and because of the
booze
because booze is actually just sugar
unless it's vodka in which case it's
potato
and also sugar welcome to analyzing
booze beyond
shitty there goes our potential bud
light sponsorship i will say
if you're in the bud light seltzer aisle
and you have a choice
don't choose strawberry oh my god this
is some kind of genius
anti-commercial i'm sure of it black
cherry is the move if you're gonna do it
do the black cherry there you go he's
got a favorite
i got a favorite but strawberry it's
cloying
that's my one wine word it's cloying
it's trying too hard
i know um all right and more news
hey more news back to the news
back to all the news that's fit to copy
and paste um
dave filoni oh we love him we love him
yeah [ __ ] without him you don't get
like baby yodas and stuff
you don't at all um he is back in the
animation world
yeah for star wars the bad batch
these are all the clones right yes the
series five
voiced by d bradley baker really he
plays
all of those clones that feels like some
kind of scam
i mean good for him listen i will voice
one character
in animation world we know you
voice when you get paid to do a gig
generally and i guess it's
maybe scale gig or whatever to [ __ ] at
the standard rate you get paid to do the
voice
and a spare voice so like even the
people who work
on our show you'll have them be like you
know all right here's your main dialogue
and then colette who's our voice
director is like um oh you know i need
some mala in the crowd can you give me
say like eternia
and like so people who play main
characters
are also throwing in a secondary voice
so
you know five in the bad match i think
yeah but he should get paid five times
though well
that's true because it's five main parts
it's not him doing a main part and some
wall
and then like you know the the cabbage
merchant in the corner
it was like oh that's a nice tasty
cabbage let me tell you this dude's so
[ __ ] talented
he'd pull them all off i watched this
man do the
voice of a monster like like
and i'm i'm doing and i sound ridiculous
he did it and i swear to you it was
insane
how realistic it sounded like and i kept
looking for like
a reverb tool or you know like [ __ ]
arm batman like kind of thing
and it was a man literally doing it with
his his vocal cords it was astounding so
if he could do that he could [ __ ] and
he's already done this he's voiced these
characters before he'll continue doing
it but you're right pay him five times
is the problem with that marcus is
disney and they don't have any money
whatsoever
no i can't imagine how they would scrape
that i remember having uh
having phil lamar behind the booth with
me for for a black man beyond
and it's not only is it amazing that a
dude can have that many voices in him
but he can at the drop of a dime give
you that voice that he did
ten years ago it's like hey man what's
jon stewart sound like and he'll dig
right into that voice
how do you do that like i get it if
that's your job for like six months and
so every day you show up and you gotta
be jon stewart
but that was a long time ago and still
it can whip it out and he gets he's just
[ __ ] got it
he's uh he's uh i don't know if they
announced
or not he's uh
here i've seen him recently have you now
yeah
well that's good to you i've heard him a
lot more recently
and then we'll just leave it at that and
scene
um what else we got uh so yeah dave
filoni the bad batch
it's uh gonna premiere in 2021 which
means that they have already been at
work on it for a while
that's true as we know how great time to
be doing animation indeed
as long as you got time you we got the
beer
miller beer certainly not bud no bud
light seltzer
not so much with that um but other
elsewhere in the disney plus universe
while that was good news we have a
little bit of bad news
no we do come on it's friday we don't
need any more bad news
i'm sorry but falcon in the winter
soldier is going to take a little longer
to come to your screens
why because kovid uh yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] this dreaded disease there i
finally said it
yeah come out in favor of [ __ ] this
you had a disease
um yeah come on i was looking forward
what about wanda vision
um wanna vision seems to still be on
track but before
after [ __ ] yeah um
it was a globetrotting series that
production had stopped in march
um they were in like puerto rico and
puerto rico had some
like historic earthquakes they had to
pause filming there
they're supposed to go back to europe
for some more production all of it got
shut down because of kobits so there's
no way
they're going to make their their
projected august release date mark we
know
this is our happy place why are they
denying us our happy place
because sometimes bad things happen
wear a mask would you please wash your
hands so i could watch
falcon and the winter soldier when i'm
supposed to
god damn it yeah i mean i think judging
by
how production is beginning to ramp back
up overseas in europe and prague and
spain and yeah isn't the batman going
back to work
batman's going back to work in london
there's you know carnival row the second
season had stopped
um production for a while and they're
about to heat back up again in prague
like because europe kind of figured out
what to do
with covid like they had it bad in the
beginning
and then they're like oh it turns out if
we just shut everything down and pay
everybody to stay home
nobody will want to leave their house
and restart the economy
good idea let's try that here you know
uh turns out you know most other first
world nations have figured this out
and so they get to go back to work and
they get to have live sports again
you know the story was bad enough when
it was like
falcon and winter soldier delayed now
you gotta lay this other [ __ ] on now
we're not europe to either
i know yes we're not here um all right
so that's gonna be delayed
that's gonna be delayed [ __ ] a doodle
dude that sucks
yeah i mean we will get the mandalorian
season two yeah
when is that october for sure yeah we
know that we do
it's on track for an october release
because they shot everything and they
wrap production and so
woohoo hello
[Laughter]
uh well that's good news that is good
news but less so good with the falcon
winter soldier because i was really
looking forward to that yeah me too
i want my marvel series honestly wanda
vision's the one i'm really looking
forward to that looks f
i bet you that's a mind [ __ ] it looks
trippy as hell yeah i can't wait man
and i like them both i think they're
both good together and i was sad when
she lost her boyfriend
her love yeah you know like i like and
if it's what i think it is where she's
just like
psychotically bringing him back to life
and [ __ ]
that's i'm [ __ ] in that'll be
heartbreaking funny and heartbreaking
i mean i wonder if there's a world in
which did you ever read house of m
yeah in the comics yeah yeah yeah
they're doing a version of that um
they could if they wanted to and i'm not
giving anything i don't know anything
from anything
but house of m was sort of responsible
for
culling the mutant populations when she
was like no more mutants
and just like basically it's hey look
we're back to [ __ ] the x-men again
the ogx men there's a world in which you
know being of that
unlimited cosmic power could also say
wouldn't mutants be cool
yeah or lots more mutants i'd like
mutants please
like oh hey now there's mutants in the
marvel universe that hadn't been before
like if you needed a way to introduce
them that's a very good way to do so
remember in infinity war
after the snap and everybody's
disappearing and she's holding
vision and then she turns to dust and
[ __ ]
she almost looks relieved
to be [ __ ] dying because she's like
she
[ __ ] loved that robot so much yeah i
look forward i think that series gonna
be fantastic
as in mine um black adam
is still a movie that they're making the
dc dwayne the rock johnson
yeah he was used to be a shazam bad guy
but he turned into sort of anti-hero
he did you know there was some level of
redemption um
and i'm sure that whatever version that
the rock is starring in
he's not going to be straight up bad guy
no he'll be an anti-hero for sure
is it uh will they tie in shazam or no
um did you hear me go i'll [ __ ] [ __ ]
sam
i'll be heading to the prom after we're
done with this broadcast
you've got to read
yes
i don't know if if uh if captain marvel
shazam is gonna be a part of it i would
hope so
um simply because why you wouldn't cross
over those two
characters given their the very basic
dna that crosses them over um
but they did cast an atom smasher
yes the young lad who at one point was
attached to be
he-man was that's right centennial is
that his name centennial centennial
he was attached to be he-man the
live-action he
i don't know where that stands now but
adam smasher uh did we ever see him
before in anything have they ever don't
believe we have i mean never in a cw
show or anything
no i think he was in justice league um
the animated series
i think we got a taste of adam smasher
there but never never anything you can
get big right
you can get big you can rearrange his
matter at will manipulate his size
strength and durability
got a creepy mask too yeah you tell you
right now that kid's too pretty they
ain't gonna put no mask on them that
whole movie
it's gonna be like you know the the very
last basket is gonna be like a david
bowie [ __ ] lightning strike
painting on his face they're like why
would we cover up that money that's the
boy from all the boys i've loved before
yeah
all the boys i loved before well they'll
just put like you know one little atom
like across his face there there it is
like look he's smashing
smash adam smasher but yeah
would you like to smash atoms with me
everybody smash the atoms men
and women alike are like yes done
where do i sign up um weird uh
character to include and uh if you put a
gun to my head and said
you name one [ __ ] other hero gonna be
in a black adam movie i'd be like i
don't know what you're saying
[Laughter]
never would i pick i'll give you 78
guesses i would never
no never hit him sorry
black racer no i would have guessed him
before
[ __ ] atom smasher uh so yes that is
supposed to go into production
in uh early 2021 um he's been talking
about that for a while
duane johnson i remember before before
the artist formerly known as the rock
you know he was you know every time i
look to his instagram he is either
eating an enormous amount of food um
pushing his tequila brand
we we do that how can we don't look like
him i know because we also don't do the
third thing which is work out every
other [ __ ] day
[ __ ] clanging and banging with the rock
are you sure it's not the second thing
maybe we needed tequila to push
and then we'll look like him might be
that pesky third thing hey
damn it de nuccio uh
tequila what's the nucho snooch to the
nooch
nice yeah it sounds vaguely yeah yeah it
still it has an
air fund to it it does denuccio um
i don't like that [ __ ] i taste
i i'm okay with booze tequila i had one
bad night and that's
that was it forever yeah yeah do you
ever drink spoiled milk
yes did you ever i mean i love it but
smoker's poor book you know what do you
like like an alien from alien nation
give me that spoiled milk oh come here
francisco give me that spoiled milk
i'm drunk i worked at a deli i was
telling my kid this the other day i was
like i worked at the galley deli when i
was
16 years old like over the summer and we
made like breakfast sandwiches we were
open to like five in the morning because
the
fishing boats went out of there and
stuff and
there was this dude named skip larger
dude
and he uh every morning got like a pork
roll egg and cheese kind of sandwich and
he got
a nestle carton of nestle quick
chocolate milk
so every day grabs it opens it [ __ ]
downs half of it and [ __ ] chitchat's at
the counter and stuff while he's waiting
for a sandwich
he [ __ ] opens this thing takes a big
gulp
and i've i'll never forget i've never
tasted spoiled milk in my life
but i never will because of this guy's
reaction he was just like
and [ __ ] projectile vomited right on
the [ __ ] floor man dropped the carton
lumpy [ __ ] came out of it like oh it was
so [ __ ] bad so
the other day my wife was like your
kid's so weird she smells
everything before she eats it or drinks
it i was like that might be genetic
because like i'm the same way man even
sometimes with water i'm like
just because i never want to have that
experience that old skip had at the
galley
back in 1987. [ __ ] i gotta
get my head out of the past my daughter
does the same thing well like literally
it's a [ __ ] chicken nugget she'd be
like
what do you think i'm doing like this is
a big poison
dude it's sauce it smells like it's not
so much she distrusts you it's just like
she distrust the nugget i guess but i'm
like i just made that for you that's a
[ __ ] pancake that i just made from
scratch
for you old skip didn't think that quick
was trying to [ __ ] him over and yet he
took a big gulp and he got [ __ ] in the
throat
that's a shifty rabbit
[ __ ] in the throat right in the
[ __ ] trout
um so yeah so no tequila for the
the smart empire i don't think so we
need something more fun
tequila mix strawberries it's like
strawberry jack
strawberry margarita mix because i could
drink the mix
it's just no booze in there yeah
sugar water love it
um hey we were talking about netflix
before i have more netflix news because
they're [ __ ] netflix they are the
business they are making
and this this makes me makes the indie
comic fan and me
crazy happy a usagi yojimbo
yeah animated show yeah stan sakai is
like long running like you started this
thing in the [ __ ] 80s 1984 the rabbit
the rabbit samurai and and they're doing
who's doing it
um famous it's netflix is producing it
james wan is among the executive
producers
um yeah so [ __ ] dark horse is in on
that
atomic monster with his james bond james
warren's company did you say live action
uh cg cg yeah it would be tough
it's honestly like in a world where
everyone's snapping up ip and [ __ ]
that that's ages old decades old yeah
well known to a point but also like wide
open to be exploited to a brand new
audience and now
animation technology has caught up to
the place where you're like we can make
this [ __ ] look like [ __ ] pixar
yeah the dude's got decades worth of
stories let's go to work
for sure and like we haven't quite seen
this before you know a flung and rabbits
who wielding swords like samurais but
feudal japan like all of that and like
demons and ghosts and
anthropomorphic nuggets it seems ready
made for a cartoon
surprised that it hasn't happened before
long before this
everything gets its day and everything
gets its day but i'm so excited for that
simply because like yeah
i knew about that i think i heard within
the halls of
netflix about that like months ago and i
was like holy [ __ ] are you kidding me
that's pretty awesome yeah that's very
cool um
you've uh you've met keanu reeves right
uh i have and most recently i
interviewed him for the bill and ted
panel that's running on uh
comic-con online next week does uh
did he strike you as a comic book fan
um was that part of the interaction no
but
like he did play constantine he did so
there's some comic book you know blood
in him for sure
he's writing a comic book now i heard
that yeah
an ageless man indeed who hunts
other men what does he do um it's it's a
little bit ageless man who loves
other men that sounds hot
that's a comic book i'm in sounds like
one of mark's video games
there's a lot of moral ambiguity in it
i'm looking for a man what are you
hunting them sorta
kinda what are you gonna do with him
well let's just leave it at i'm looking
for a man all right
oh that's uh smart i says to myself when
i saw this earlier online i said
this is a guy who's normally like well
i'll go where fortunes take me who's got
a good script
this guy's like look man i got a story i
want to tell yeah in a world where i'm
like john [ __ ] wick
why can't i be busy according to reeves
um the character was born 80 000 years
ago half man his father's a war god
um and he's battled through the ages in
places of great war and conflict
even though he's immortal in a way he
also has to hide himself and pretend to
die and then keep on moving on
[ __ ] in yeah so it's a little bit it
seems like the highlander's in the air
it's a little bit country and a little
bit rock and roll
highlander is in the air man it really
is i mean old guard was was
sort of a take on that plus now like who
ain't gonna be like hey keanu can we
make a movie of your comic book
you know what i'm saying he ain't gonna
have to schlep it around to places going
like
hi i was in bill and ted um maybe you've
seen my work anyway this is a comic book
maybe a little buddha was more your
speed
i don't know if you watch hockey movies
but i was in
young blood back in the 80s uh my own
private idaho was a favorite
god he was so good in that movie um that
movie i drove into new york
by myself to go see that movie when it
opened in like what 1989 no 1990
let's say two or something like that i
saw it alone
in a movie theater except for one other
like a matinee at a movie theater like
i forget which one it was but it was in
manhattan and uh there was
one other dude in the theater and the
movie's about like gay hustlers
uh and so most of the movie i kept
looking up and then every once a while
i'd look over and the dude was like
looking right at me
just slowly moving closer i kept waiting
for it i was one seat
once again i was like wow who's tapping
when in new york
at an unattended matinee about gay
hustlers my own private screening
he's uh he's doing the book through boom
boom comics yes
and boom has a first look deal uh with
netflix
so it seems as if there's gonna be a
movie of a thing
you better believe it keanu has already
stated that he'd kind of like to play
this character
who was drawn in the book to look just
like him just like i'm the cover of the
book it's like it's keanu himself
yeah um wow what boom how how happy is
boom right now
yeah holy [ __ ] they had their deal at
fox and fox sort of went away and then
they ended up in netflix and then they
got [ __ ] keanu ran a comic book for
them
they'll do fine yeah they're doing all
right they'll do okay
um good for them good for keanu good for
us sounds like we'll get another keanu
thing
something his heart will really be into
because it's his
it will be it's who's he did say that he
has been a comic book fan
as a young kid huh it's like oh man i'd
love to play wolverine he said as a
young kid and
everybody's like yes we would like that
too did he say that he did say that
yeah he could do it now he could the
ageless keanu reeves
i mean kinda and also it's just like
redefine what wolverine is at that point
no reason you can't catch wolverine
later in life do you think if they made
him
keanu reeves that that hugh jackman
would be like well i mean
could have just stuck with me i mean i
mean i know i did the last story but
i was old wolverine you got another old
wolverine i mean
it's your world do what you want i just
think it's weird i know i mean you can
if you need him to be young wolverine
give me some of that [ __ ] scorsese
magic and
make me young again and also it's like
you don't have to be dead you know
wolverine he just he heals so
the first shot of the movie is my hand
comes up from the earth and
go on from there and that was also in
some distant future
whatever [ __ ] we're good now um what
else we got
um dc would were you
were you as much a fan of these books as
i was which ones
um marvel had the uh official handbook
to the marvel universe yes
and dc had who's who oh who's who in the
dc universe i've gone to this universe
binders still
with the loose leaf version they just
remember that which is so [ __ ] smart
and they sold them out of it wasn't even
here's all the a's here's all the b's
they were all mixed up so you couldn't
just pick like i'll just get the batman
one and stuff but the batman one was a
big deal
the batman page was drawn by
none other than norm bryfold if i
remember correctly
yeah i spent long hours between the the
marvel universe and the dc who's who are
just literally just reading
[ __ ] honestly sometimes it was more
entertaining than the stories just all
the character backstories the things
they could do
like i remember the official you know
marvel
handbook what was it called marvel
handbook to the marvel universe the one
where they talked about
um bullseye where like he could kill
with a paper clip
you know [ __ ] like that we're like yeah
just just the like
the powers and special abilities section
was always like
tell me how this works yeah and it was
just like as a d
kid you know a nerd who's just like okay
let's talk about power classes
um i'm pretty sure that captain america
and batman like
captain america's got the age on batman
because he's actually a super soldier
where batman's just rich
like he's olympic level for certain but
he's not super human level
that's true but batman's got a broken
heart and that'll take you a long way
um but dc is finally releasing who's who
omnibuses like the big ass [ __ ] heart
oh that [ __ ] big book the absolute
versions
volume one is 1328 pages long
that's a book worth owning that's a
coffee table book right or [ __ ] yeah
um so it's let's see illustrated by a
wide range of top parties all of the
greatest talents of the last 30 years
probably
and so the volume one will it's clearly
gonna have to do more than this but
it'll collect who's who the definitive
director of the dc universe 1 through 26
the who's who update in 1987 uh another
update from 1988
then material from action comics annual
number two batman
like it's just this list of awesome [ __ ]
um sold sold 150 bucks
for the almost 1300 why i'd have paid
double you might have to anyway yeah um
but april 2021
i'm in god that's a good idea yeah an
idea whose time has come
so smart um this is
i think just this past week was the 20th
anniversary
of x-men the movie the first one the
first one
is that right yeah and nobody celebrated
it
well it's a weird time it is but yeah
2000 that movie came out
wow man and uh and and very much set us
on the path
to where we are foggy worked on it kevin
feige was an associate producer
one of the first uh stan lee cameos
and we had didn't we have a then tom
santo came and told us how he got
negotiated that story
yeah dig into the if this was a comic
book it would have a little box
that says like c issue 202
it was the stan memorial yes when we did
the stand memorial
tom got up told the great story yeah um
but yeah i mean blade had come before it
or is what did mark call it
a viking funeral for a jewish legend
so eloquently put um
but yeah if without x-men you don't get
the marvel universe as we know it
the the sort of the the the arms race
between marvel and dc
everybody and their grandmother wanting
to have a superhero universe to build
a massive continuity machine out of
like there had been comic book movies
before that for certain i mean
superman clearly batman batman
spider-man spider-man
no that's spider-man's free spider-man
spider-man you get blade before then
you've got the turtles movie
blade makes marvel viable for the first
time
yeah prior to brilliant blade marvel
can't buy a hit
yeah that and then there's a movie
before then which nobody cares
yeah there's blade and then x-men and
suddenly people like oh and
x-men was blade was super [ __ ]
surprising but
didn't necessarily play like a comic
book movie it could have been a just a
vampire flick
x-men was surprising because even fox
didn't think it was going to be anything
and it showed that
hey man 10 years of watching those
[ __ ] cartoons built an audience like
they know these characters are and [ __ ]
yes i mean if you give them
like the casting pretty well i mean
yes patrick stewart seems born to play
professor x
but hugh jackman as logan was like mad
controversial at the time like look he's
two times even supposed to be him it was
dew gray scott
yeah originally cast and then tom cruise
wouldn't let him out of mission
impossible movie and so they had to
cast their second guy and that was
usually the unknown
australian actor that was a song and
dance man that was his first big break
and you know fans were like he should be
like bob hoskins he should be [ __ ]
short and hairy the fans in boston are
like that
they're all from from uh from brockton
and vermont maine
brockton mass he should be short and
[ __ ] hairy
that ain't that ain't doctor xavier
he ought to be [ __ ] younger
that guy's never spent that's that's
captain picad
what's pika doing in there
[Laughter]
number one get it yeah gene pickett
that's not my [ __ ] professor x
pickard
um but yeah and and so without without
that movie
we don't get where we are today so you
know [ __ ] raise a glass to the x-men
just perhaps not the director no less
him i feel like we should all treat
the the same way that rami malik treated
brian singer when he won an oscar
for bohemian rhapsody was never mention
that guy's name
um what else we got going on well the
last uh
bit is the is the not particularly good
bit here we go
here we go brace yourselves brace
yourselves um
if if you are uh is this news or
personal this is
both is it really it is it is both um a
fella who
i i'm not gonna say i was like close
friends with but i knew him
relatively well i would see him twice a
year grant imahara yes
um who was you probably if you know him
you know him
best as a co-host mythbusters for a
bunch of years
and then the white rabbit project which
was basically mythbusters with all the
original hosts he then took the netflix
but he had been um sort of a staple in
the nerd world
as basically the nicest guy you've ever
met
um i was talking to jc before and he was
like yeah he just
he was like everybody's best friend and
treated you like he was your best friend
even if you've only met him once he was
a bar regular jc
uh yeah he was here a bunch but you just
find him here
you know once a month twice a month um
and everybody who hung out
here was a friend of his so he was
here in spirit even if he wasn't
physically here
um well yeah like i would run into it
and at parties at comic con it was
always like hey mark how you doing
what's happening what's going on like
you just
he wanted to know a lot about what you
were up to even if you only ever saw him
once a year
he was always incredibly warm and
incredibly open and
super [ __ ] excited to do what he does
i mean he was a
he was a robotics [ __ ] kid growing up
he was a
electronic engineer growing up he ended
up at ilm
and like he built models for star wars
and and helped design
you know much of what you saw in the
prequels the last thing that i saw him
work on
was a like life-sized baby yoda
that he [ __ ] built in his lab that's
gorgeous and wonderful and does all the
motion and the moving he
built baby yoda holy [ __ ] because he's
that guy who just likes to build that
[ __ ]
he built it to bring to children's
hospitals
because he had built a bb-8
and then they realize that bb-8 rolls
all over the floor and kids go and
hug bb-8 and it's full of garbage from
the floor and germs
so baby yoda was to bring to children's
hospitals
how beautiful is that yeah but uh in his
years at ilm he was a chief model maker
specializing in animatronics and he
worked on the prequels matrix reloaded
and revolutions galaxy quest van helsing
lost world harassing park ai
and terminator 3. wow among other things
and so he died at 49 of the brain
aneurysm
jesus just like the healthiest guy in
the world
you know like the last time i saw him he
was heading off to vacation in hawaii
and just bolt from the blue for no good
reason there's no
rhyme or there's nothing he did wrong
and nothing that he could have prevented
just
one morning didn't happen god damn it so
um yeah like i i didn't know him
terribly well
liked him every time i saw him but i
have a bunch of friends who knew him
very well
and so it was it was just the latest uh
the latest entry in the log of the
shittiest year on record
of like really really why him kind of
thing
why him kind of thing like of of all of
all the people it's gonna happen to not
that you wish ill on anybody
some anybody's more than others but
like that dude seemed destined to live a
long happy life
and making other people happy in the
process but it was not to be
so while we're raising a glass to x-men
let's also raise a glass to grant a
mahara
who left us far too soon and left far
too many people who loved him in his
wake
to all the people that loved him and uh
to his family
and uh anyone who's ever touched by the
man's work man
uh our heart goes out to you yeah like i
i heard from a lot of
friends especially asian friends that he
was for them
you know a little bit what like levar
burton was for me which is like here's
this asian guy out in this
business like visible professional nerd
you know and like maybe that means
there's space for me in this business
too and
and it's it's a it's a devastating blow
to everybody but
he was he was a bit of a of a flag to
rally around we lost a trailblazer it
sounds like
we did indeed so yes rest in peace
uh [ __ ] maybe start with that next time
you think so
i mean i debated it it's tough to like
end the show where you're like well
what's the point the good die young and
we're all screwed
um you know what we should go to
question we should take some fun that
will put a smile on our faces pull us
out of this
jc is the proprietor this year cantina
it's coming villainy cantina
uh jc what questions he monitors our
our uh youtube comments section braves
it
each and every episode uh ali fourth sir
and he gets attacked for not
picking your questions so go easy on
them tonight ladies and gentlemen jc
what did the people at home want to know
all right uh
primearch359
uh what characters would you write a
romance movie in the dc
marvel uh universe with
uh more romance uh like no action scenes
it's like a
rom-com what marvel or dc characters
would you write a wrong comment
marvel or dc all the big fight scenes
happen off camera oh that's my kind of
movie
that's the movie i was born to make um
let's see
hmm
you got any ideas i got one go
batman and robin oh
such low-hanging fruit such a good idea
but i would totally watch the uh the
douglas cirque kind of hot house
kind of cloistered romance of this uh
sort of middle-aged man and this
it's of gods and monsters right it's
[Laughter]
you know what in a world where they're
doing that harley quinn cartoon where
everyone curses
all bets are off anything's possible
totally just just give me the longing
glances give me the call me
by your name of superhero dramas
with bruce wayne and dick grayson
living up to their names you're gonna
get a call
about [ __ ] two days fandom is gonna
be like we'd like you to not be involved
actually no we're gonna scrub all that
footage thanks
um let's see uh who in the marvel world
[Music]
matt murdock and karen page
i enjoyed their romance in the comics uh
you know tough to make a rom-com out of
those two it'd have to be
before she went off and did porn
um but yeah i like them
although i i would say vision in the
scarlet witch but they're apparently
doing it right now
on the dc side uh
either dick and coriander
or dick and babs
all right either way dick
dick we're gonna get some dick you can't
like get a batman romantic story going i
mean i did a little bit in uh
widening gyre but you know dick grayson
always a little bit more
human so you can kind of tell that story
and not have to worry about like the
problem with the batman story is like
every night literally the dude's on
patrol
but you know dick grace you get the
impression he takes a night or two down
to just
be himself he's not that driven yeah
exactly uh
i'm mad about my parents death but you
know i'm dealing with it
yeah talk to a guy about it it's all
good
i uh i also think that there's
absolutely
and and i guess that lois and clark was
supposed to be this yeah
but the the the great innovation of the
dick donner superman was the invention
of the love triangle between two people
true between superman lois and clark
kent
and just to play that would be kind of
great
you know just to play the the you know
the coming out of rooms and ducking into
rooms and where the hell were you
and and then you get the french bedroom
verse of it all and you get to have like
philadelphia story you get to have like
news people
and like journalisms and like all of
that stuff like this is good yeah
there's a lot there
i like his answer and also i mean scott
summers and jean grey and logan
like i feel like love triangles give you
the most juice
and so that can be like the love
actually of the [ __ ]
marvel universe where like here's the
guy who's totally in love with the girl
who's in love with another guy
and nothing is ever going to change that
but that's not going to stop logan from
wanting gene gray
it's true there's a hard on the actor
playing
cyclops because you don't get to work
his eyes
in a rom-com yeah no he's all but that's
something you play in the script where
wolverine's like you could look in my
eyes at least
come on gene and then that moment where
gene figures out that she can actually
hold the beams back
which i think they they did in the
comics yeah at some point
in the movie too remember he takes i
think it's in the
first one where he takes him off and she
sees his eyes for one second it's a
really nice moment
actually where she's like because she
sees into like
what what's in the beyond the ruby
quartz visor and the cosmic infinite of
his red freaky eyes
that's a that's a cool moment um
all right next question all right uh
this is from
coco lozano um
and they were wondering if you had to
choose characters to be
teachers in a middle school who would
they choose and what subjects would they
teach
i mean logan clearly teaches shop
[Laughter]
so so superhero characters are teachers
in a middle school
vic sage teaches journalism
okay ooh vandal savage teaches history
oh that's great ivy of course
uh teaches horticulture mm-hmm victor
von fries teaches chemistry
dick grayson teaches uh jim
um peter parker teaches photography
didn't he become a teacher at one point
he does yeah like empire state
university yeah that's right esu
um
clark kent is the only [ __ ] boy scout
headmaster you trust
[Laughter]
i think that's pretty good yeah we
went a lot further than i thought we
would oh totally
all right third question all right this
is take us home here we go
kirk gibson which is apparently the hero
of the 1988 world series
uh is that a sports thing yeah it's a
sports thing it's a basic good dodger
thing
it's a baseball thing uh
he wants to know if each of you wrote a
movie for the other to direct
which jean or sorry wrote a movie for
the other to direct which
genre would it be who would score
the music and what is jc's role in each
film
that's a little self-serving nice nice
yeah we're all chosen
just a little like chumming for the
moderator there like let's put jc in
this
yeah i know how to get this question
through
[Laughter]
um let's see what would i write for mark
genre the score and what does jc
do the genre is
like uh i know this ain't technically a
genre but i would go like a sh
in a sham shyamalan direction
because mark always has like and then
this happens and you're like oh [ __ ]
that's good
so you'd want to give them something
with some twists and
you know a hook that was you didn't see
coming and stuff a sixth senseian
seinzian kind of thing sixth sentence
who would score it
that is a good music nerd question who's
the guy that scored
um um [ __ ] i just rewatched it recently
and i was like
this score just sounds like john
carpenter
oh watchman who scored watchmen oh trent
rezner
i just rewatched it again i'm like this
sounds like john carpenter it feels like
right straight out of carpenter i pick
him or john carpenter
okay i mean if you're going to get a guy
who sounds like john carpenter might as
well
go to john he's still making music and
then what's the other question
and then what does jc do jc
is uh
producer not the financial producer but
the guy who's getting paid
to produce the movie the working
producer the one without whom you don't
get the movie made
and [ __ ] not the like glorified in name
only producer who
shows up you know when the star's on set
and [ __ ] the one who's in the trenches
every day making the movie that's who jc
is
okay i think for you i'm either going
um kind of mad mad mad mad world
kind of mad cap uh chasey thing
or like low level heist oh go low level
heist yeah go like
i could pull one of those off like the
[ __ ] like like from a porn store
pretty low level or a weed store or a
weed store that makes more sense i was
going to go like exotic bird feathers
nice like the very specific kind of
insane like
somebody stole gordy howe's winning puck
for the x
stanley cup thing i am in in like flynn
and it's set in canada sure the heist is
at the hockey hall of fame
yes i'm there look what just happened i
just you
sold me a ticket i want to see this
movie that i'm gonna direct
uh who does the score i'm i'm going to
say
um danny elfman
nice he he passed on dogma so this would
be good for me this would be good to
close a loop where
you know 21 years later i'm like oh not
so good for this picture are you
well done sir yeah um and what does jc
do
jc's the fluffer oh [ __ ]
look at that man all hands on dick i
don't mean grayson
well done man that's a good job i'll be
honest with you i think you're getting
off better on my show
but i'm also going to say not a lot of
fluffing required on this so you just
get paid and also to be fair
like when you're producing the movie you
like literally have to work hard
every day if you're the fluffer you just
have to work to get someone hard
once a day yeah good trade off
10 minutes and you're out if you're good
at it
then you just sit in your trailer then
just cry yeah
you're like i could have been a producer
i just wanted an easier job
i'll never play the piano again i can't
get the stick off my hand
a stick of betrayal oh damn spot
uh that's the end of the questions all
right we can do more do we got one more
uh we can do one more all right fine
find a good one
um where you're not referenced in the
question uh
this one is what video game would mark
like to see made into a movie and what
movie would you like to see
as a side-scrolling video game oh side
scrolling
there you go i would like to uh let me
see
um well yeah it's a no-brainer i'd like
to
play the uh infinity saga as a side
scroller
you know sega genesis version maybe
you know a super nintendo version like
the old star wars games
that'd be cool that's what i'm looking
for what about you
um i'm tempted to say i would like a
good assassin's creed
movie um the one that we got with uh
with
fast fast bender not good and his
gigantic
manhood yes no wow that's impressive
yeah i mean we've seen it yeah not like
you know well
because we're insiders in hollywood
everyone who's seen that one movie's
seen it pretty much shame
is that it and there is no shame there
no that's the
real shame is that we're all not that
blessed that's a dude who's just like
showing off his dick and i get it
yeah that would be a rough uh rough show
for you to work on
magneto indeed shit's magnetic it's one
of the polls
[Music]
um video game that hasn't been made into
a movie that i'd like to see into a
movie
um
pitfall yeah [ __ ] yeah dwayne the rock
johnson can be in that movie
i mean it feels like he's already done
the poster i feel like i've already seen
him swinging from a vine
he's got to jump over three crocodiles
that all open their mouths at the same
time
yep it's a lot of timing a lot of skill
if he gets bitten by
a scorpion you hear me me
i mean and he only has 20 minutes to do
it that's it we're out that's
i'm in i can find it in that movie 20
minute [ __ ] pitfall
how much to get the rock for a 20-minute
movie oh but with a 20-minute pitfall
adventure you can get five per movie
and so you can have five different stars
in five different pitfall adventures
it's like clue
yeah but with pitfalls yeah it's like
here's john hamm's pitfall
yes here's scarlett johansson's pitfall
i think we're on to something here and
then like the last one
and they all got to [ __ ] die except
for the last one he gets to the treasure
or she
leslie let's be honest with you who
leslie jones i was going tiffany haddish
but yes okay
you know what team up together done um
but somebody gets there where the others
don't
and so you pass their corpses along the
way
this is hot [ __ ] divisions call
us first we gotta get the rights from
activision hey netflix
um wow we just can't call it pitfall
but we could just pretty much take this
idea straight to netflix
i know but calling it pitfalls the
triumph
where people like they took pitfall and
turned it into a movie like
barely but yeah
and it became the number seven most
watched
netflix original moving household ever
watched us
killed dwayne johnson 20 minutes in and
uh who's the who's the lady who played
hera
oh kate amber heard no no
not her not mira hera from uh hella not
hera hella oh
kate blanchette kate blanchett she's one
of them
um like or it's like the rock and then
like jim j
bullock we blew all of our legs
we blew all of our money on the rock all
we have to know that you go the rock
you go who were in the big movies they
had oh um
take one each hemsworth there you go
charlize
there you go um mock wahlberg
there you go this movie's awfully white
i know we need one black person
or more well if we're only doing five in
20 minutes we got four right there
um where's the where's my list of their
movies
who have they ever had a what's their
biggest
black movie at netflix is there any in
the top 10 there
um irishman no
but i never saw triple frontier i bet
you there's a black dude in there
you could get marshall ali
[ __ ] yeah right he makes everything
better denzel
look at [ __ ] denzel's kill dunzel in
the forest
oh no don't kill him he gets the one
he's like all right all right
we're gonna do this when he gets there
the alligator didn't land on us
we landed on that alligator don't you
ever in your entire life
think that i won't get over this [ __ ]
hole that alligator joke
is fantastic because it's true you do
land
on the alligator
um there it is we've answered four
of three questions that's how serious we
take our jobs did you have a good time
ladies and gentlemen
i did yeah i sure did man there's your
friday night we're gonna give it back to
you now you're completely updated
go wake up your loved ones if you're
back east and tell them
hey man did you you know who is
being in this like i forget all the
stories we did but you know what i'm
talking about go wake people up and tell
them
brother's making a movie go wake him up
and tell him that uh
ryan gosling gonna be in that movie or
wait till morning probably better yeah
you know this will go down easier in the
morning yeah
just like me and mark easier in the
morning way easier in the morning
um it's better a lovely uh good time
hanging out with you folks man
it's the one bright spot in a very uh
tumultuous
2020. i'm standing come here yeah and
be with friends and chit-chat about [ __ ]
that matters
uh we can't do that without jc opening
up the bar
to us thank you jc thanks jc say how do
you mother for me
[Laughter]
without andrew switching cameras switch
the cameras three times andrew show them
that you exist
yeah look at that [ __ ] somewhere a bunch
of kids are just like it's like pokemon
it's like a libertarian keys spells
right now um
uh don't forget man uh we can't do the
show without an audience
and tonight's audience is deacon thanks
for being here brett
thank you for dropping off those tickets
man well done
uh but we got no show without you guys
thanks for watching but there is no
[ __ ] show without the guy
to my left give it up for mr mark
bernardin thank you sir
and that my good friends in the culture
of pop
is fat man beyond for this week i'm
kevin smith i'm mark bernard tune in
next week same fat time same fat channel
uh oh before i go yeah if you want to
order movies right now
anywhere in the united states go to
moviespopup.com goldbelly we'll send you
a movie meal kit you can make the whole
thing at home you can make a cow tipper
at home
nice my last minute commercial thank you
i would have been driving home going
[ __ ]
celebrity show off celebrity show i've
been watching at home i've been my my
wife just he was in it did you did
you it's not on the air yet though oh
that's right it goes on this week
right now mark is in the episode that's
up on youtube and then on tuesday
that will be on tbs you're going to be
on tv i have not seen my wife laugh as
hard as she laughed at the
tater tot gun she liked it she lost her
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's awesome and that's a that's a
jersey girl right there yep something
she always wanted to try her whole life
she's like finally he did it
one of us somebody if only there was
pork roll and not gun too
as long as she calls a pork roll oh yeah
only tell her
nonsense she's on the right side of that
border bunch of east coast cats right
now are like yeah
finally the content i've been waiting
for say more things that are just easy
clothes
[Laughter]
we work regional ladies and gentlemen
i've been edging all show come on
and there it is mark has beat us off
into the into the sunset
for fat man beyond i've been kevin smith
i'm mark bernard
tune in next time same fat time same fat
channels podcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith for the good of
all creed
so say we all it's so much better
you